You can add color to
your websites using CSS.
However, in order to do this, you first
need to understand how color is encoded.
To start, color is composed of light.
All light, including the light being
emitted from your screen right now,
is composed of a certain proportion
of red, green, and blue light.
The amount of red, green, and blue light
is what determines the color you see.
For example, the combination of red and
green light with the absence of blue
light is what makes the color yellow.
The combination of green and
blue light with the absence of red
light is what makes the color cyan.
And there are countless
variations in between.
The different combinations of red,
green, and
blue light make up 16,777,216 colors.
That's a lot of colors.
When writing CSS, you express color by
specifying the amount of red, green,
and blue light that should be present.
This can be done in one of two ways.
In the first way, which is commonly
referred to as RGB, each amount of red,
green, and blue light is written as
a decimal number between 0 and 255.
0 being the lowest value or
no presence of light and
255 being the highest value or
100% presence of the light.
For example, if I wanted to change
the background color of this page
to magenta, then I'd write
background-color: rgb (255, 0, 255).
The first 255 specifies red light.
The 0 specifies green light.
And the second 255 specifies blue light.
The combination of these
values produces magenta.
In the second way,
which is called hexadecimal or hex for
short, each amount of red, green, and
blue light is written as a hexadecimal
number between the values 00 and FF.
00, which is just 0 in decimal, and
FF, which is just 255 in decimal.
If you're unfamiliar with how
hexadecimal works, check below for
some helpful links.
Using the same example for magenta,
I would instead write background-color,
a pound sign, this tells the browser
I'm using hex code, and then ff00ff.
The first ff, which is really just
255 in decimal, specifies red light.
00, which is just 0 in decimal,
specifies green light.
And the second ff, which again is 255
in decimal specifies the blue light.
This encoding also produces
the color magenta.
Now colors aren't always as
straightforward as primary and
secondary colors.
Like I said,
there are millions of different
colors you can express using CSS.
Often what can be helpful is using
a color picker to get the exact shade,
tint, and tone for
the color you're trying to use.
You've probably seen a color picker
before if you've ever used a graphics or
design tool.
But did you know that most browsers
actually come with their own built-in
color picker?
Check it out.
Here i have Google Chrome open,
and I'm looking at BBC's website.
If I inspect the navigation bar and
try changing the background color,
you can see that by clicking
on the color square,
I open Google Chrome's color picker.
With the color picker,
I can use the eyedropper to select
another color on the screen.
I can change the hue by
dragging the slider.
I can select a color, and
I can toggle between the hex and
RGB encodings of the color.